[Musik]
sally backt zusammen mit cosima back
sally für deren freund micah eine
tenniscourt jetzt kommt das schwierigste
phase okay jetzt eine riesige
buttercremetorte mit geheimen botschaft
hier und jetzt noch ein die torten queen
erobert den center court gefestigten ja
ist richtig schön kochen selber backt
sonntag 15 uhr bei vox
hallo herzlich willkommen so sally welt
heute mache ich alles geburtstagstorte
ella wird schon zwei jahre alt
unglaublich ich erinnere mich noch an
meine schwangerschaft updates und jetzt
wird sie schon 2 letztes jahr habe ich
in der bauernhof torte gemacht und in
diesem jahr bekommt sie eine masche
torte vielleicht kennt der ein oder
andere von euch die serie und zwar ist
mascher das ist aus dem russischen
fernsehen eine kinderserie und mascha
das ist diese kleine figur
lieblingsfigur das ist ein kleines
mädchen die lebt bei ihrem bär mal
schauen wer ist die serie und ich glaub
ich glaube ich ein bisschen hyperaktiv
und ganz so sagt eines risses
hyperaktives nicht schreiben aber dies
halt echt mega süß und er liebt die
serie als sie darf sie ab und zu
anschauen und ab und zu schaut zu sehr
auch auf russisch an das ist schon auch
immer ziemlich lustig weil ich dann
nicht so viel verstehen aber das ist die
ganz ganz süße figur und heute möchte
ich euch zeigen wie ich mach ja gemacht
habe und zwar mit hilfe einer schablone
technik und mit dieser technik können
die wirklich jede beliebige torte jede
beliebige figur aus jedem film
nachmachen als torte innen drin habe ich
einen schokoladenkuchen mit banane
richtig lecker und richtig tolle und
leckere schokoladencreme ich zeige jetzt
zuerst mal wie man die torte herstellt
und zeigt euch dafür die zutaten für den
bananen teil so schön mein schutz für
den bananen tag brauche ich drei 150
gramm zucker vier reifen bananen etwas
salz etwas vanille extrakt 175 gramm
sonnenblumenöl 210
ich habe ich ein päckchen backpulver
drei viertel teelöffel zimt ein viertel
teelöffel natron eine prise american
gemahlene ich habe ich noch 40 gramm
packung pulver und ich brauchte in saft
von der halben zitrone
jetzt kann ich den bananen teig
herstellen
dafür gebe ich zuerst einmal die eier in
eine rührschüssel die lassen sich am
besten auf schlagen wenn sie zimmer warm
sind
da kommt der zucker mieter zogen etwas
salz und von alex hat und während die
masse jetzt hier für etwa vier bis fünf
minuten cremig verrührt wird kann ich
schon mal die bananen schälen und ihr
seht auch diesen richtig schön braun von
außen und innen sind sie einfach richtig
schön süß also je braunau umso besser
dann sind sie reif und vor allem habt
ihr einfach so auch eine tolle
resteverwertung weil bei meinen kindern
ist auch oft wollen die braun bananen
nicht mehr so murat auch und hebt sie
dann immer auf und dann kann ich immer
einen leckeren kuchen backen und die
werde ich jetzt hier drin einfach mit so
einem zerstampft zu drücken ihr könnt
aber auch eine gabel nehmen oder einfach
die hände
[Musik]
die masse ist jetzt schon weiß cremig
und ich habe jetzt auch bereits den
zitronensaft mit dem banalen pury
verrührt jetzt kommt hier das öl mit
rein dann auch das banalen püree und die
zwei zutaten die werden jetzt ganz kurz
ein gerührt
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich hier schon mal die
trockenen zutaten zu hören und die dann
auch ganz kurz mal niedriger stufe in
den teig werden
[Musik]
und jetzt will ich den teig in eine
vorbereitete back for rain da habe ich
jetzt einen bug ring genommen auf eine
dauer barth folie und das perforierte
blech gesetzt und den ring auf 24 cm
eingestellt da kommt der teig jetzt rein
und wird einfach gleichmäßig verteilt
und so kommt er jetzt in den
vorgeheizten backofen bei 170 grad ober
unterhitze für etwa 40 bis 45 minuten
ich mache auf jeden fall die stäbchen
probe und nehmen dann heraus und lassen
über nacht abkühlen
[Musik]
der kuchen ist gebacken und ich habe ihn
über nacht komplett abkühlen lassen
abgedeckt natürlich ein bisschen zu
dunkel geraten ich hatte ihnen drei
minuten länger drin
samira hat auch schon geschimpft aber
ist nicht schlimm ist nicht verbrannt
und der deckel wieder sowieso
weggeschnitten also alles gut
hier habe ich jetzt eine schablone von
mascha und zwar habe ich hier so ein
wind ausgedruckt und dann eben einfach
ihre gesichtsform ausgeschnitten die
brauche ich dann gleich zum bearbeiten
das ganze kann ich jetzt hier mal stehen
lassen und zeigt euch jetzt die creme
die ich zu bereiten werde ihr könnt
jetzt zum beispiel eine garage neben was
super gut zu banal passen würde
oder auch eine schokoladen buttercreme
und die mache ich jetzt weil sie
wirklich auch super lecker schmeckt ich
zeige euch mal die zutaten für die
buttercreme brauch ich 6 170 gramm 300
gramm zucker 500 gramm weiche butter 50
gramm puderzucker und 200 gramm herren
schokolade
ich nehme jetzt zuerst einmal das eiweiß
und den zukam und zwar kommen die hier
in eine schüssel
ich habe hier bereits ein wasserbad
aufgestellt und das wasser auch schon
aufkochen lassen
jetzt kommt das eiweiß hier rein
gemeinsam mit dem zucker und das eiweiß
muss pasteurisiert werden also wird
jetzt erhitzt auf über 60 grad dann
sterben einfach alle keime ab dann habt
ihr zum beispiel auch keine probleme mit
salmonellen und die creme ist daneben
auch ein paar tage länger haltbar
ich lasse jetzt das wasser wieder
aufkochen und ihr könnt jetzt im
idealfall mit einem thermometer arbeiten
damit wirklich die temperatur von über
60 grad erreicht wird oder er ist
einfach so lange bis der zucker sich
auflöst und dann hat man im normalfall
auch 60 grad
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt die 60 grad erreicht und
wenn ihr kein thermometer habt könnt ihr
einfach mit den fingern reingehen und
reiben und wenn ihr keinen zucker mehr
zwischen den fingern spürt dann ist die
creme wirklich perfekt jetzt nehme ich
sehr herunter und jetzt musste er kalt
gerührt werden
ich mache das jetzt hier in der
küchenmaschine weil es eben einfacher
geht nicht auf die hände frei für andere
dinge
ihr könnt aber natürlich auch in hand
rück geräten die creme bietet einfach so
lange gerührt bis sie richtig schön fest
ist und vor allem kalt ist und als
kleiner tipp von mir damit die creme
schön kalt geschlagen werden kann könnt
ihr die masse jetzt auch in der kalten
küche einfach umfüllen
dann geht es ein bisschen schneller die
zwischenzeit habe ich übrigens genutzt
um her die tortenböden durchzuschneiden
und jetzt kann ich in der zwischenzeit
auch noch die schokolade schmelzen das
wasser ist ja schon heiß genug der herd
es bereits aus und ich sehe ich hier
wieder drüber und kann die herren
schokolade schmelzen so sieht jetzt die
weiße masse aus richtig lecker sieht aus
wie eine wolke und ich habe jetzt hier
auch schon die butter mit dem
puderzucker etwa fünf bis zehn minuten
weiß cremig verrührt und die schokolade
ist auch schon geschmolzen
jetzt kann ich einfach die eismasse
unter die butter heben und natürlich
auch einfach die schokolade dazu rühren
[Musik]
fertig ist die leckere buttercreme und
die gelingt wirklich super einfach ihr
müsst ihr im prinzip nur beachten dass
die eier massa natürlich kalt genug
gerührt ist ansonsten schmilzt die
butter
wenn es aber doch mal zu warm ist es
auch nicht schlimm dann könnte das
einfach in die küchenmaschine oder mit
dem handrührgerät wieder einspannen und
dann einfach noch mal glatt rühren
und jetzt kann die torte befüllt werden
jetzt nehme ich ein bisschen was von der
buttercreme und streiks hier auf mein
krieg kann ich mal probieren ja
eigentlich hört keiner buttercreme nicht
mag es geht auch fehlen aber ich muss
sagen diese buttercreme also die
italienische und auch das ist eigentlich
mehr des frankfurter krieg wie sondern
das ist ja so schokolade schokolade
schmeckt echt wie mousse au chocolat sie
die müsst ihr wirklich probieren setze
ich hier den ersten boden drauf
so hatte ich muss meine torte machen
jetzt kommt hier ein bisschen
buttercreme drauf und dann kann ich so
die komplette torte füllen
[Musik]
der dritten boden den immer jetzt auch
der winter mitte nicht so ganz schön
hoch aber ist gar nicht schlimm denn der
wird so besser zugeschnitten und jetzt
stelle ich die torte so in den
kühlschrank für etwa eine halbe stunde
bis stunde
man merkt dann auch wenn er ein bisschen
fester wird und dann können wir nämlich
zu schneiden und die restliche
buttercreme die verstecke ich jetzt am
liebsten ich brauche hier nämlich noch
nicht sagt demokratie jetzt
jetzt ist die patin abgekühlt und jetzt
nehme ich meine vorlage also die maske
dann ist sie nur darauf achten dass sie
ein bild erwischt wo man wirklich
frontal in die kamera schaut also das
einfach beide gesichtshälften ungefähr
gleich sind und jetzt könnt ihr das hier
drauf legen
ich habe einfach beim einem drucker auf
300 prozent vergrößert also ihr müsst
einfach schauen dass es von der größe
her passt und jetzt kann ich hier einmal
außen rum schneiden
[Musik]
und jetzt nehme ich einfach ein bisschen
was von diesem kuchen resten und kann
ich hier das loch so ein bisschen
ausgleichen
hier außenrum schneide ich so ein
bisschen leicht abgerundet weg das ist
einfach nicht so eckig und kantig
aussieht und wer möchte kann jetzt auch
gerne an dieser stelle die wangen noch
so ein bisschen auffüllen mit dem
kuchenteig und da könnte dann wirklich
die schablone nehmen und euch drauf
legen und die partie wo die wangen sind
ganz wenig aufhören
[Musik]
und jetzt nehme ich die creme und mache
hier einfach schon mal eine erste
schicht drauf die bindet die ganzen
kuchen krümmel
dann kommen die torte für 20 minuten in
den kühlschrank und dann werde ich noch
mal mit der restlichen creme ein
bisschen glatt streichen und die kuchen
reste die könnte jetzt zum beispiel
nehmen um so kleine kügelchen zu formen
cake pops zum beispiel oder können sie
jetzt einfach schon verlassen
[Musik]
jetzt hier 750 gramm gelben von dort
weich geknetet und den rolle ich jetzt
auf etwas becker stärker aus und hier
ist jetzt einfach nur wichtig dass ihr
hier die farben von den haaren also
nicht vom gesicht sondern von den haaren
mascher hat der blonde haare und
deswegen nehme ich jetzt einfach ein
bisschen geld und das kann ich jetzt
hier über die torte legen jetzt einfach
schön mit den händen ein bisschen
anpassen
es muss also nicht ganz glatt sein da
kommt ja gleich noch eine schicht drüber
die überreste nehme ich dann weg ich
habe mich hier bei der schablone
übrigens schon das auge und den mund
ausgeschnitten da kann ich einfach
schauen ob es für den proportionen her
passt natürlich auch wo später das
gesicht hin muss die schablone lege ich
jetzt kurz zur seite und die torte kommt
nochmal in den kühlschrank und jetzt
möchte ich mir auch etwas weiß etwas
gelb rot und ein bisschen braun einfach
so eine richtig schöne hautfarbe für
manches gesicht
laut schablone habe ich jetzt hier oben
sondern part wo die haare sind dh den
part und von dort kann ich mir sparen so
viel von der möchte auch keiner auf der
torte daher schneidig hier einfach den
teil weg und jetzt kann ich das gesicht
hier draufkleben entweder nehmen wir
jetzt ein bisschen wasser bisschen
s-bahn kleber oder ihr könnt auch ein
bisschen back prinz william zum ankleben
das habe ich jetzt genommen weil es
darstellt
und jetzt kurz mit den händen und mit
den fingern so ein bisschen ausdünnen
und vor allem hierbei den wangen schön
darüber legen
[Musik]
jetzt nehme ich die schablone und gerade
da wo die nasenlöcher sinn mache ich ein
kleines loch von dem da am besten der
nadel oder zum beispiel einen
zahnstocher
jetzt könnt ihr die schablone nämlich
auf die torte legen so dass es passt und
jetzt mit einem modell werkzeug einmal
den wunsch nach fahren und so ist ihr
einfach immer ganz genau auf welcher
position eben augen mund nase und so
weiter sind bei der nase mache ich jetzt
so dass ich jetzt hier unten auch mit
einem modell werkzeug einfach so ein
bisschen die nasenspitze nach oben
drücke und daneben auch rechts und links
die nasenflügel so ein bisschen formen
[Musik]
während sie mir jetzt noch die torte
einstreicht kann entweder mit dem
gesicht weitermachen und zwar nehme ich
jetzt auch wieder ein modell ihr
werkzeug ihr könnt aber zum beispiel
auch einen löffel nehmen oder die
rückseite von dem löffel und jetzt hier
bei den augen die partie einfach so ein
bisschen ein drittel
und wenn ihr möchtet dann drückt ihr das
nur ein oder ihr könnt sogar einfach
ausschneiden so entsteht eine kleine
kuhle für den weißen teil vom auge
[Musik]
mit hilfe der ausgeschnittenen schablone
die jetzt hier wunderbar rein passt
werde ich jetzt von dort aus soll
ungefähr in der stärke wie hier die
hautfarbe und es dann einfach mit etwas
zucker kleber hier einsetzen
[Musik]
die linie unterhalb der oberlippe habe
ich jetzt hier auch eingedrückt so sieht
das ganze ein bisschen realistischer aus
und jetzt vor mich zuerst einmal den
mund weiter jetzt fahre ich für den mund
ein bisschen hautfarbe die hautfarbe mit
rot gemischt und hier habe ich auch
bereits zum teil rot und schwarz
ausgerollt zuerst brauche ich jetzt den
schwarzen teil das heißt ich nehme die
schablone und kann es in schwarzem bart
ausschneiden
auch gott zeigt diesmal in die kamera so
wollte
nein
[Musik]
jetzt reiche hier ein bisschen kleber
drauf dann kommt zuerst das schwarze
teil und einfach immer so ein bisschen
mit den fingern anpassen
da schneidet jetzt einen kleinen teil
wieder weg da kommt nämlich rot hin also
die zunge
[Musik]
dann kommen wir jetzt noch zwei kleine
weiße zähne hin
und jetzt soll ich für die oberlippe und
die unterlippe so ein bisschen was von
diesem hellen rosa aus und klebt es als
dünne lange schlange hin
[Musik]
nämlich ein bisschen rote pulver farbe
auf so einen richtig schönen großen
flauschigen pinsel auf aber wirklich
schon ganz ganz kleines bisschen
und damit werden in wangen so ein
bisschen gepudert jetzt sind die augen
an der reihe dafür brauche ich jetzt ein
aussteller der ungefähr so groß ist wie
hier die iris da hab ich jetzt noch
spritzt hülle und ich von den kleineren
ausstecher habe ich auch nur spritzte
und dies so groß wie die pupille und
jetzt nämlich die große sprits töne und
drückt es jetzt hier ganz vorsichtig an
mit der kleine spritztour steche ich
jetzt hier zwei schwarze kreise aus und
das ist dann die pupille und jetzt könnt
ihr beispielsweise einen grünen
lebensmittel stift nehmen und damit hier
innen die ehre so ein bisschen an mal
das werde ich jetzt auch gleich machen
und dann nehme ich noch ein bisschen
metallic farbig habe ich sie einmal in
hellgrün und dunkelgrün und wer das
ganze noch mit dem pinsel ausmalen und
anschließend dann noch einen weißen
punkt in die pupille setzen
[Musik]
wäre es dann soweit habt dann können
jetzt noch mal ein modell werkzeug
nehmen und gerade unter dem auge diese
mini falte nachzeichnen
jetzt kommt ihr über dem auge noch ein
kleines augen lebt das mache ich jetzt
wieder auf hautfarbe
[Musik]
jetzt fehlen noch maschers wimpern
dicken dir gerne auch mit brauner
lebensmittelfarbe anmalen oder ihr könnt
sie zum beispiel auch mit von der in
ganz ganz kleinen mini stückchen
draufkleben
[Musik]
an machers mund fehlen jetzt nur noch
die falten auf der einen seite habe ich
selbst bereits gemacht und auf der
anderen seite kann ich die fall jetzt
auch mit hilfe von dem modell werkzeug
eindrücken und jetzt in die haare an der
reihe darauf habe ich jetzt wieder ein
bisschen gelb ausgerollt diesmal nicht
ganz so dünn damit ich es einfach so ein
bisschen strukturieren kann
jetzt wird der gelbe park auch angeklebt
unternehmen die jetzt wieder die
schablone und können dann einfach
schauen wie groß der teil ungefähr sein
muss
[Musik]
und jetzt nehme ich meine modelle
werkzeug ihr könnt auch ein stumpfes
messer nehmen und einfach so ein
bisschen einsetzen so dass ein haar
struktur entsteht
[Musik]
und jetzt nämlich braune und schwarze
farbe und katzen paar schattierungen in
die haare machen
[Musik]
jetzt ist das skateboard an der reihe
das soll ja auch richtig schön werden
und dafür habe ich jetzt ein bisschen
blauen und weißen sondern vermischt und
dann wirklich so marmoriert gelassen und
das kann man jetzt hier schön außenrum
legen und dann ein bisschen anpassen
[Musik]
jetzt fehlen natürlich nach maschers
typisches haarband
so wie hier hat sie immer so ein langes
haar band bzw ein kopftuch auf und da
wir aber jetzt fondant ein bisschen
eingesperrt mit lebensmittelfarbe haften
und da wollte ich jetzt ein langes
dünnes band aus jetzt schlage ich hier
einen teil 1 und messe einmal die höhe
der torte und kann dann das band zu
breit eben auch zu schneiden
[Musik]
jetzt reiche ich hier an den rand der
tortur einfach ein bisschen kleber und
setzte das tuch dann von oben nach unten
[Musik]
hier unten am kind schneide ich dann den
über ist einfach mit einer schere weg
und schaue einfach auch dass ich das
geld ein bisschen überdecke was machst
du echt schön schutz danke
da hat jetzt eine richtige profitierte
hingehauen damit unten das kopftuch
aufgebunden aussieht kann ich jetzt hier
noch zwei so schlafen machen und zwar
nehmt ihr da wieder so ein kleines
stückchen faltet das war ein bisschen
nach innen als im prinzip gibt es da
keine richtige form sondern einfach nur
noch entfalten dann sieht nämlich nicht
so flach aus und dann klebe ich das hier
rechts und links an
[Musik]
und kann hier in die mitte noch so einen
kleinen beutel setzen also so den knoten
sozusagen
und wenn ihr dann fertig seid könnt ihr
einfach einen sauberen pinsel nehmen und
zum beispiel hier außen die bäcker
stärke ganz einfach wieder wegfuhren
und es geht wirklich nur mit beckers
stärke also wenn ihr puderzucker oder
stärke nehmt also speisestärke zum
ausrollen von von dort dann kriegt man
das einfach nicht spurenlos weg und wenn
ihr denn extra ganz wollt dann nehmen
wir noch ein bisschen back trance
bringen jetzt ist mascher fertig jetzt
fehlen nur noch ihre süßen
sommersprossen die hab ich jetzt auf der
zeichnung nicht gesehen aber hier auf
der puppe sind sie wirklich drauf und
diesen job goldig und die x ich jetzt
einfach mit einem roten lebensmittel
stift auf die banken ich ziehe mich
nicht ist was du machst etwas an ihrer
gerade noch ich weiß die macht die raupe
nimmersatt unsere meere hat ohne vorlage
gearbeitet hier wird zwar das bild
ausgedruckte börse schloss fertig obwohl
schön schutz richtig hübsch sanierer
also meine tochter ist jetzt auch fertig
und ich muss sagen die torte sie also
die gefällt mir optisch zeigt rot ich
glaube auch du hast du ja ganz gut
gefallen wird und dass sie ihre masche
erkennen wird die können wir natürlich
erst morgen probieren denn morgen wird
und verkleinerung auf zwei jahre an
aber da machen wir auf jeden fall noch
ein paar bilder und die töne helfen sich
anbieten auf jede form wir machen den
ausbau widmen walt disney figuren nicht
sehen wirklich alles will ich hoffe dass
sich dieses tutorial spaß gemacht hat
vielleicht probiert sie auch mal aus und
schreibt uns auf jeden fall auf eure
kinder auch so große macher fans sind
hat er manchmal sitzt allen sogar da und
guckt sich die russischen folgen an und
spricht dann auch russisch gehen auch
samira kann schon noch ein russisches
mord an einer frau deutsch was so
[Musik]
es war nicht wahr auch schon unser kind
besser als multikulti aber egal und
jetzt zeigen wir noch von mir als
wunderschöner torte ist echt voll
schöner
das ist auch so
[Musik]
alstom bisher film kann wir zeigen mal
die die kaffeemaschine läuft immer dann
wenn wir reden
das ist so schmal dass ist die raupe
nimmersatt genau die grauen die hatten
die iss nimmersatt gelb genau die hat
magen-darm-probleme das sieht mein
gesicht dies richtig richtig im
startdrittel voll hübsch aber jetzt mal
bei abend und ich lasse nicht an ihrer
privaten bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]
zusammen mit cosima bahceli für deren
freund micah eine tenniscourt jetzt
kommt das schwierigste phase okay jetzt
eine riesige buttercremetorte mit geheim
botschaft hier kommt noch ein die torten
queen erobert diensten talk gefestigten
ja es richtig schwachen serie backt
sonntag 15 uhr bei vox
[Musik]
hallo emma unsere kleine maus heute
wirst du zwei jahre alt und die zeit
verging so schnell und wir lieben dich
über alles und guck mal die kleine
schwester samira habt ihr eine richtig
schöne torte gemacht die kleine raupe
nimmersatt von mir an was möchtest du
dir immer sagen fünf jahren ist er so
alt wie du mir mal was mit auf den weg
geben ja was denn ich mache ich was und
was kann sie vielleicht bis dahin lernen
so trocken machen
maxim beibringen du bist ja auch eine
ganz ganz tolle lehrerin für die elf von
deere lanz ist soviel java die macht
man's nach wie ich ja du dich auch ihr
großes vorbild
die wird immer so sein wie du willst du
ja noch mal sagen dass wir haben haben
der papa nicht so sehr weil es so und
ist raus
auch nach fünf jahren das video anschaut
dann ist vielleicht griechenland und
schwarz noch mal fünf jahren das video
anschauen da wurden wir nur sagen dass
du dich über alles linie haben sagt
diesmal ja und dieser mir schaut ja fünf
jahren das video an und hatte bis dahin
schon wieder vergessen was sie heute
hier gemacht hat wir noch zwei jahre in
der zukunft wir lieben dich auch vor
allem also wir sehen uns in fünf jahren
genau und samir hat jetzt der gegenwart
komme ich geb dir ein kuss nicht
gebildet worden schlafen und wenn wir
älter bist gebracht
[Gelächter]